nach dieser schimmel skandalen nun eine
dax luftnummer was bedeutet das denn für
den ruf deutschlands in der welt herr
gabriel
der ist natürlich bestätigte ein
finanzplatz deutschland und es gibt ja
das recht kritik an auf allen seiten
nicht nur für das unternehmen selbst da
haben wir viele menschen jetzt auch eine
menge geld verloren sondern auch an der
aufsicht der rechtsaufsicht
finanzminister hat das auch gesagt dass
dort offensichtlich was passieren muss
der wirtschaftsprüfer es massiv in der
kritik war ja seit langer zeit die
financial times berichtet hat dass da
geht es nicht mit rechten dingen zugeht
und keiner hat reagiert im gegenteil ist
noch versucht worden die mit
journalisten mundtot zu machen
da gibt es spiele in der welt die jetzt
sagen werden ganze mal sehen die
deutschen haben das nicht im griff
und dass das ein bisschen meine sorge
dass in den letzten jahren es ja
häufiger mal zweifel an diesen
qualitätsmerkmal made in germany kann
denken sie mal daran wie lange wir
gebraucht haben um so ein flughafen
fertig zu kriegen was mit der
unpünktlichkeit deutsche bahn technik
ist wie lange wir vorhaben brauchen bis
eine bahnstrecke einer autobahn oder ein
radweg gebaut ist es nicht so dass das
im ausland keiner merkt und das
verrückte ist das image deutschland ist
eigentlich zu den ganz eine ganz andere
qualität pünktlichkeit
leistungsfähigkeit das ist sozusagen das
was als positives vorurteil gegenüber
dem land expert und das haben wir in den
letzten jahren relativ häufig in frage
gestellt und es ist lange her dass
beispielsweise chinesen zu den deutschen
und ihrer ingenieur geht es auf geblickt
haben inzwischen fahndung züge in china
pünktlicher als in deutschland